[Музика]
Привіт усім, мене звати Анна, і
сьогодні ми поговоримо про
молодіжні клуби та організації, де ви
дивитеся урок англійської мови,
тому давайте почнемо, перш ніж ми перейдемо до
нашої теми, насправді у вас було домашнє
завдання  на сьогодні,
тому ви повинні були вивчити слова з
попереднього уроку,
зараз ми перевіримо, наскільки добре ви
запам’ятали слова,
тому наше завдання — заповнити
речення словами, які ви можете побачити на
дошці,
два з цих слів  додатково це означає,
що нам не
потрібно їх використовувати,
тому давайте подивимося на слова, давайте
переглянемо їх, а потім ми прочитаємо
текст,
тому поважаємо унікальний
наряд, невдячний марнотратник,
дивні статуї догори та бутик, тому
всі ці слова були вивчені на останньому
тепер урок,
давайте з’ясуємо, які прогалини потребують
слова, тож почнемо,
я не модник, я не схильний до
всіх модних тенденцій, вони змінюються так швидко,
я думаю, що стиль важливіший.
Я ніколи не планую, перш ніж вийти з дому,
я знаю, який одяг виглядає ні  це на мене, тому
я не витрачаю
час на це, оскільки я не залежний від
моди,
я не купую дорогий одяг, так що так,
я точно не
віддаю перевагу робити покупки в брендових магазинах масового ринку
або в місцевих магазинах я  Я не прихильник
розкоші,
я розумію, що одяг може відображати
ваше спілкування,
тому я просто намагаюся виглядати акуратно та мило,
але коли я виходжу з друзями, я
можу надіти щось справді незвичайне,
навіть щось у будь-якому випадку,
я думаю, що це також дуже важливий вибір людей
у тому, що  вони хочуть носити, ми всі такі
різні
і близькі, може допомогти показати, як з
людьми все добре, зараз давайте подивимося
на текст
ще раз, і тепер я сподіваюся, що у вас
уже є ідеї,
які слова використовувати в кожному пропуску, а тепер
давайте перевіримо  твої ідеї,
так що розрив номер один я не модник,
я, як правило,
не роблю щось із кожною модною
тенденцією, тому, коли ми говоримо про модні
тенденції,
ми можемо використовувати слово слідувати, тому я схильний
не слідувати модним тенденціям
номер два, я думаю, що стиль більше
важливо, і я ніколи не планую
щось  дуже важливо, перш ніж я піду з дому, тому
стиль важливіший,
ми говоримо про одяг, тому, ймовірно,
людина планує набір одягу тут, ми
будемо використовувати слово
одяг наступний
я не залежний від моди я не купую
дорогий одяг
так, я точно не
людина, про яку ми тут говоримо,
мабуть, людину, яка не
витрачає багато грошей на одяг, ми
називаємо людину, яка навпаки, навпаки,
витрачає, тому людину, яка витрачає
багато  гроші і, як ви бачите, ця
людина не з цього типу, тому
номер чотири зараз я не прихильник розкоші,
що це може бути, про що ми говоримо,
ми говоримо про бутики, магазини
масового ринку, брендові магазини
і так далі,  людина не любить
розкішні
бутики п'ятий я розумію, що одяг
може відображати ваше соціальне
щось, тому яке слово, на вашу думку,
відповідає
цьому розриву в соціальному статусі, звичайно,
ваше становище в суспільстві номер шість,
тому я можу одягнути щось справді незвичайне
навіть дещо  Яка
повага, унікальне, непомітне чи дивне,
тож, ймовірно, ми говоримо про
щось дивне
чи щось дивне
номер сім, я думаю, що дуже важливо
робити щось із вибором людей
близько,
то що ми з ними робимо, якщо показуємо,
що ми
цінуємо їх, ми  з ними все гаразд, ми
насправді
поважаємо, тому ми поважаємо вибір людей,
і останній, останній проміжок номер
вісім
і близький, може допомогти показати, як
щось у людей, тому тут ми
описуємо людей, і ми говоримо про
те, наскільки особлива кожна людина
тут, ми будемо  використовуйте слово унікальний
добре зараз, оскільки ми згадали
інформацію, яку ви
дізналися на попередньому уроці, ми можемо
рухатися вперед,
тому, як це вже згадувалося
сьогодні, ми будемо говорити про
молодіжні організації, але що таке молодіжна
організація
насправді, тому тут ви  можна побачити
визначення молодіжна організація – це тип
організації
, зосереджений на забезпеченні діяльності
та соціалізації
для підлітків, тому в основному це схоже
на кл.  ub,
куди ви можете піти, і ви можете розкрити свої
таланти,
ви можете спілкуватися, і ви можете
спілкуватися з людьми
, які мають однакові таланти або інтереси,
тому насправді є багато різних
організацій у всьому світі,
вони є національними, вони є в усьому світі, а тепер
давайте подивимося на  найвідоміші з
них,
тож тут ви можете побачити логотипи,
емблеми організацій 4-h
, це насправді
американська мережа студентська мережа Erasmus, щоб ви могли
зрозуміти, що це щось більше
пов'язане з
університетами, що насправді є
загальноєвропейською
студентською організацією скаутський рух
також відомі як скаути або скаути, про які ви,
напевно, чули,
що ще одна
місцева національна скаутська організація України,
тож останнє тут Українська
молодіжна асоціація
тепер давайте подивимося на кожну
організацію окремо
, щоб ви дізналися більше про  їх,
тож давайте подивимося на перший
тут, це 4-h,
оскільки ви вже знаєте, що це наша
мережа
студентів s  шкільні діти та його мета
– розвивати громадянську
відповідальність та життєві навички,
іншу асоціацію
для молоді – студентську мережу Erasmus,
її мета – підтримувати та
розвивати обмін студентами
на місцевому національному та міжнародному
рівнях,
тому в основному це означає, що ви можете вступити
до університету
в Європі і навчатися там протягом року,
наприклад,
що щодо наступного скаутський
рух, ймовірно, один з найвідоміших
рухів у всьому світі,
його мета насправді полягає в тому, щоб
сприяти розвитку молодих людей
у досягненні їх повного фізичного ін
електуального емоційного со
іального та духовного  потенціали
ще один - це фактично українська
частина скаутської
організації скаутського руху це плюс,
вже досить важлива і досить
відома в україні мета сприяти
патріотичному вихованню та
самоосвіті української молоді
і ось на картинці ви насправді можете
побачити
поштова марка,
створена до 100-річчя  сарій
пластового руху
і останнім є Українська молодіжна
асоціація. Метою асоціації є об'єднання
української молоді
в усьому світі та виховання
людей, які дорожать українською
культурою та національною самобутністю,
тому в цих організаціях студенти та
діти зазвичай об'єднуються разом.  вони займаються
різними видами діяльності
і намагаються розвиватися як у
соціальних аспектах, так і
в художніх аспектах, давайте поглянемо
на запитання,
чи належите ви до будь-яких клубів у старшій
школі,
чи берете участь у будь-яких молодіжних клубах чи
організаціях,
то що з тобою і зараз  що ви вже
чули про організації, які існують в
україні
та вони також існують по всьому світу
в європі в сша у британії чи хотіли б ви
взяти участь у таких молодіжних
організаціях
і які молодіжні організації ви знаєте,
що існують
у Великій Британії  тож
тепер, коли ви задумалися над цими
питаннями, давайте перейдемо до іншого завдання, а
тепер ми читаємо текст про
головний молодіжний орган
і після тексту
ми перевіримо, наскільки добре ви пам'ятаєте
факти,
тож давайте прочитаємо та послухаємо основні молодіжні
організації
у Великобританії у Великобританії
існує ряд молодіжних організацій,
які працюють під керівництвом Британської молодіжної
ради,
оскільки рада була заснована  у 1949
р. налічується близько 60 молодіжних
організацій найпопулярнішими та відомими
організаціями є
національна спілка студентів,
асоціації скаутів та дівчат-гідів
. Діяльність цих організацій
включає туризм для молоді
спорт веслування на каное вітрильний спорт катання на лижах
та піші прогулянки,
включаючи читання карт  орієнтування та
кулінарія
в асоціації скаутів і дівчат.
Юнаки та дівчата належать до різних
секцій,
члени якої повинні дати клятву
вірності королеві й богу
та допомагати іншим людям скаутська
асоціація
була створена в 1908 році після
появи книги
Скаутський рух для хлопчиків почався
в Англії,
але дуже швидко поширився на о  інші
країни,
окрім звичайної освіти, вони
займаються такими видами діяльності, як навчання всім
про
ведення таборів, картографування сигнальних
вузлів та надання першої
допомоги. Національна спілка студентів була
заснована в 1922
році. Метою організації було
розвиток
співпраці зі студентами
різних країн.
щоб захищати інтереси студентів коледжів і
шкіл організація не є політичною,
вони тепер кидають виклик студентам формувати
майбутнє освіти
та створювати кращий світ,
тому молодіжні організації у Великобританії були
створені для задоволення потреб молодих
людей різного походження
та цілей  добре, тепер, коли ми
прочитали текст, давайте перевіримо ваше розуміння,
тому перевірте себе тут, ви можете побачити
п’ять питань, які мають на меті перевірити,
наскільки добре ви
пам’ятаєте факти, згадані в тексті, давайте
почнемо з першого,
тому byc
означає британський молодіжний клуб  b
Британська молодіжна рада чи c
Британська молодіжна рада чи пам'ятаєте ви,
що саме
було  згадується в тексті, що це
британська молодіжна рада,
наступний номер два в молодіжних
організаціях
кулінарія не входить до списку
заходів
, це правда чи неправда, чи вчаться
готувати в скаутській організації,
наприклад, звичайно, це
неправда  навчіться готувати
номер три рух скаутів
розпочався
в Англії Шотландія
Уельс США,
тому, ймовірно, люди знають, що США
є однією з найбільших країн з
найпопулярнішим скаутським рухом,
але насправді він почався в Англії
номер чотири, національна спілка
студентів
було засновано в 1992,
1929 або 1922 роках.
Що ви пам'ятаєте з тексту,
звичайно, це відповідь c
1922 р. добре
і п'яте питання. Тепер молодіжні
організації у
Великобританії створені для обслуговування
потреб королеви людей Великобританії
літніх людей або молоді  людей,
тому, звичайно, ми виберемо молодих
людей для цього,
добре, тепер, коли ми перевірили ваше
розуміння,
давайте перейдемо до іншого  складні речі,
оскільки ви пам’ятаєте цю тему, ми
говоримо про інфінітив і
герундій, тому що таке герундій, це
дієслово, яке трансформується в іменник шляхом
додавання
ing, тому ви вже знаєте деякі факти
про герундій
, тепер вам просто
потрібно  запам'ятати,
щоб тут ми могли побачити дієслова, за якими
зазвичай йдуть
герундій або jannah
ing давайте подивимося слова
заперечує він заперечував скоєння злочину
згадав про те, що він згадав, що йде до того
коледжу
уявіть, що він уявляє, що працюватиме там одного
дня
терпіти я терпів її розмову
зрозуміти  Я розумію, що його звільнення
пов’язане з поїздкою до
Японії
раз на місяць.
Він завершив ремонт будинку.
Він повідомив, що вона
вкрала гроші, очікував, що
я прибуду пізно,
і останній з них відкликав Тома
за допомогою своєї кредитної картки в магазині,
тому ці дієслова:  зазвичай
після інфінітиву також
є набір дієслів
, за якими йдуть два плюс інфінітив
let'  Подивіться і на ці,
тому першим словом буде очікувати, що
вони очікують прибути раніше, або вони
очікують, що Джулі прийде раніше, у
нас є крихітна зірочка поруч із цим словом,
і насправді
не тільки з дієсловом очікувати, давайте подивимося
на рядок  у нижній частині цього слайда
ми можемо використати об’єкт перед
інфінітивом із цими дієсловами,
а інший – intent, це не має
зірочки,
тому зазвичай за ним не стоїть
об’єкт, але за ним йде
інфінітив два плюс дієслово
відразу подивіться на  приклад, ми маємо намір
відвідати вас
наступної весни наступне слово:
прикинутися, що дитина прикидалася, що
мила, відмовитися від охорони
не дозволив їм увійти до будівельного
намету він, як правило, трохи сором’язливий,
хотів би звернути увагу, що у цього
є зірка, і це  використано
це може бути використано з об'єктом
я б вважав за краще це зробити або
я б вважав за краще, щоб він це зробив
би вважав за краще наступне
слово заслуговує, він заслуговує
на в'язницю, схоже,
його здоров'я краще
влаштувати наомі домовитися залишитися з  її
двоюрідна сестра
в  Майамі і стверджують, що вона стверджувала,
що вона принцеса, тому після цих дієслів
слідує інфінітив,
який є tu плюс дієслово ok,
тепер наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб потренуватися, звичайно,
наше завдання полягає в тому, щоб поставити дієслово в
герундій або інфінітив
з двома, щоб це могло бути  трохи
складно,
але ми можемо це зробити, тож давайте подивимося
на першу,
здається, буде дощ.
Ви пам’ятаєте, яку форму
дієслова ing
або два плюс інфінітив ми будемо використовувати
після дієслова appear
okay, правда, ви, здається,  бути
дощ, тому після появи ми використовуємо
інфінітив
число два ми маємо намір поїхати в
сільську місцевість у
ці вихідні маємо намір їхати або
збираємося їхати, який правильний,
і насправді є лише один, так що так
, це йти ми маємо намір поїхати
в сільську місцевість наступне
число речення  три я
прикидався хворим або хворим, тому мені
не довелося йти на роботу,
який з них ми будемо використовувати тут, я
прикинувся хворим, тому після того, як прикинуся, що ми будемо використовувати,
щоб бути іншим, це номер чотири, чи
можете ви уявити собі жити без
смартфон
так  ви можете собі уявити, що живете або ви можете
собі уявити
жити ми будемо використовувати live форму ing
після дієслова уявіть наступне
число п'ять підліток відмовився піти
на відпочинок з батьками,
тому підліток відмовився їхати або
підліток
відмовився йти що слідує
хм, це слово
тут ми будемо використовувати, щоб перейти, звичайно,
наступне число шість, я очікую
прибути у вівторок, тому
очікувати прибуття або очікувати прибуття,
звичайно, це має бути герундій, тому
передбачити
прибуття у вівторок номер сім,
весілля передбачає переговори
з усіма у  сім'я, перш за все,
що таке переговори,
що насправді є синонімом для розмови, щоб
спілкуватися,
переговори над цим
і слово включає, після нього
йде герундій або інфінітив
, ми вживаємо переговорів або
для переговорів, звичайно, тут ми будемо
використовувати ing,
це передбачає щось зробити  передбачає
переговори про наступне число вісім,
він заперечує крадіжку грошей, тому він заперечує
крадіжку
або він заперечує крадіжку, звичайно,
це крадіжка номер дев'ять
він стверджує, що він мільйонер, але я не
вірю йому,
тому яку форму дієслова ми будемо використовувати
після заявки
is it ing чи це інфінітив,
тут нам знадобиться інфінітив,
звичайно, він стверджує,
що він мільйонер наступний, який
я очікую  be there about seven,
яку форму дієслова ми використовуємо після
очікувати, звичайно, це інфінітив,
ми скажемо, що я очікую бути там
номер одинадцять julia reported
see the boys to police
so see or to see
вона повідомила про те, що бачить голос до
поліції
номер 12 це має тенденцію до
дощу або багато дощу в Шотландії
після дієслова tend ми будемо використовувати
інфінітив, тому
він має тенденцію до дощу номер 13
чи пам'ятаєте ви зустрічаєтеся з нею на вечірці минулого
тижня
чи пам'ятаєте ви зустрітися чи пам'ятаєте
зустріч тут ми  звісно, знадобиться герундій, то
ви пам’ятаєте, що зустрічали її
отирнадцяту, про яку вона згадувала, сх
одіть до кіно  кінотеатр
с
наш і останній тут номер 15
я б вважав за краще, щоб ви прийшли раніше, якщо ви можете,
так що ми маємо тут ing або ми
маємо інфінітив,
ми обов'язково повинні сказати, я б
вважав за краще,
щоб ви прийшли раніше, якщо ви можете добре попрацювати
виконано, ви закінчили цю
вправу, тепер ваше завдання полягає в тому, щоб
запам’ятати слова, після яких йдуть
герундій та
інфінітив, і ось ваше домашнє
завдання,
насправді вам потрібно скласти п’ять речень
з герундієм,
використовуючи слова, які ви бачите зараз,
забороняють
згадувати  уявіть собі терпіти розуміти
включати повний звіт передбачити
та пригадати, щоб за цими дієсловами
фактично слідував герундій,
тож вам потрібно буде використовувати
речення, зробивши речення ще одним завданням.
Інша частина вашого домашнього завдання —
скласти п'ять речень
з двома плюс інфінітивом, використовуючи ці
дієслова
очікувати намір прикидатися відмовлятися,
як правило, віддає перевагу заслуговувати з'являтися
упорядкувати та стверджувати, тому після цих дієслів має
бути
два плюс інфінітив, який
зазвичай є
інфінітивом
[  Музика]
[Музика]
[Музика],
тож це ваше домашнє завдання на
наступний раз,
дуже дякую за увагу
і до наступного разу
побачимось на наступному уроці
[Музика]
ви